Jim Nantz of CBS how are you Jim hello
friend yes I'm giving my voice back now
as I was fighting through the energy
wave at Arrowhead Stadium yesterday and
Kansas City and and Erie congratulations
to them they put on a great show so how
good do you think this Chiefs team is
Jim you saw last year you saw this year
better do you think I know that
obviously had a better result but they
ran into Brady last year rounded
unquestionably better talked about him
the defense was Steve spagnolo coming in
and really identifying right away that
he wanted Tyrann Mathieu to come in and
be his quarterback on defense it's a
it's it's a team Val that doesn't have a
glaring weakness not saying that defense
is the best defense of a lake but if you
look at what they've done since the 1st
of December they're up there it's not 5
times 6 and a lot of categories and they
figured out the scheme with a new coach
and five different assistants on that
side of the ball and hey there's
definitely a better Kansas City team
than a year ago and they're gonna be
good for a long time yeah I know and you
you've uh you've been around Andy Reed
for quite some time Jim not just when
he's been with the Chiefs but before all
that so do you find like he's playing
with house money here that he's a guy
that that has accomplished so much or is
one thing that he he knows that needs to
be accomplished to be the centerpiece
here
I don't think there's any question he'll
be in the Hall of Fame so when you say
is he playing with house money he's he's
got 221 wins it's the sixth most
all-time regular and closed and you look
at the five names ahead of him and a lot
of the names that are behind him and yes
you know most of them have the Lombardi
Trophy on the resume but I think he's
already done enough seven championship
game appearances two franchises going to
the Super Bowl but having said that and
he wants that he wants this next one so
badly you just know it and if it doesn't
come here this is the thing with Patrick
mahomes this team's gonna be good for a
long time and they've got great skill
players that are still young this is
going to be I'm not going to make any
crazy predictions that this is a dynasty
because a lot of good young quarterbacks
and foundations without the teams around
the AFC but you can't tell me that this
is going to be the only time that Holmes
and Reed are going to be playing in the
Super Bowl in the next ten years there
are going to be more visits so yes it
has money it's a big lift for him to get
to the game to get past this spot but he
wants that next one of course he does
Jim Nantz CBS joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show let's get a little bit
the nuts and bolts of your job your gig
so you go down on the field and then you
hand out the hon trophy what was it like
for that family to finally lift the
trophy named after the team's founder
the guy who came up coined the term
Super Bowl what was it like on that
podium with that family Jim well I think
I always have a a very big poignancy
quotient kind of as part of my DNA I'm
not saying that that is something that's
a skill or something that I have more
than anybody else in fact I think
sometimes people can be critical if
you're too sentimental or nostalgic or
see things in a context of a poignancy
but I certainly felt that what you just
perfectly described in your question
about
what was there on on that stage it was
it was a heavy in a way I mean you got
the Lamar Hunt trophy right in front of
you and yes all of that
you got normal hon who's never missed
two Super Bowls you spin it the first 53
and now we'll go back with the Chiefs
you know the widow of the great man
Lamar Hunt so yeah it had some some
serious texture to that moment I felt it
and on top of it you had this prevailing
feeling that everybody in the league
except for the Titans on this day were
thrilled for Andy Reid because he has
had so many careers that they've touched
whether it be players or former
assistants or who are now head coaches
and Andy was great on the platform and
then the top of our fight we were about
to hit a window to go to a break and I
wasn't supposed to go one more question
there stood Thailand and Travis yes and
I just myself were standing there in the
frame and I didn't ask him something
and of course Travis well I mean Jim in
terms of your career in terms of your
lush history of doing that role where
does it stand in terms of your
experience having to hang on to the
microphone with Travis Kelce grabbing it
is that a top-three a hand held sort of
kung fu grip tug of war that you had
right there Jim looks like he had a nice
situation going there yesterday
competition was part of the Olympic
Games Travis would be the silver
medalist okay all right the gold to Ray
Lewis and Super Bowl xlvii because I
felt the strength way as he grasped that
microphone and
truly truly trying to pull it away from
me and with all my might counting the
net one in my hands
somehow hold on to it with Lois really
going after it Travis I didn't feel I
just didn't feel it even though it had
hold of it right he wasn't trying to
contest we're gonna win that battle he
knew he met his match not your first
rodeo Jim let's be honest it's just not
your first rodeo and you know that if
you if you give up that mic you may not
get it back that would be it's just
that's a cardinal it's a first rule of
broadcasting right there on the podium
people at home sometimes I think wonder
why don't you just give the guy the
microphone I think I have his moment
right there's an old truism you learn
early in the businesses you know this
rich yes yes my little player Jamison
who's now just started to get in the
football mm-hmm he said even Jamison
knows right you fear you're raising him
right Jim you're raising him right
you're raising a broadcast but Courtney
said that he went back on the DVR and
Jamison and my little Fenway my little
girl
yeah back like ten times
cBS with the network my hand that's
fantastic Jim Nantz here on the Rich
Eisen show Jim I'd be remiss if I didn't
ask you the brady question since you've
been around tom and craft and Belichick
and you did that final game with with
New England and and Tennessee and I'm
just wondering what your thoughts are
what you think Brady's gonna wind up the
next couple of weeks here it's all
guesswork
I've got no inside information to share
I think we all right now are just trying
to like figure out what it feels like to
each and every one of us and I think for
many folks it's hard to see Tom in any
other jersey than the Patriots however
however and again with no inside scoop
here at all hmm it kind of feels like to
me he's gonna play some work that's
unscientific and it's going to be the
next five or six weeks some of these
decisions that are going to be made
nothing that's going to grab more
attention than that one it's going to be
fascinating to see because there are
some big names out there well and also
that the decision about resigning needs
to be made at a time before a roster
could be built and potentially presented
to Brady as as improved and and this is
the spot that he needs to decide by
March mid-march as to whether he's
coming back or not and that's part of
this very difficult equation but the
concept is and you know him very well
too is that Robert Kraft will never let
it happen
I wonder what where you might land on on
that part of the theory here Jim
you know he's a complete free agent he
can do what he wants
I'm looking at it from our little world
of media here's an interesting scenario
for you the legal release it's scheduled
and you know it's third week of April
you do the show you're great
Thank You Jess I love watching that
night that's one of my favorite sporting
events of the year I know it's not an
event I love to just start figuring out
what the schedule looks like and you
reveal it yeah well they don't put that
together with two days notice they don't
start April the 15th now if you're
constructing that schedule you're CBS
and hey the Patriots have been your
flagship team for almost 20 years and
you look at some of the games next year
with that first-place schedule and some
of the crossover not only NFC matchups
but they crossover AFC division matchups
don't have a data schedule next year
that is if you just had the New England
schedule and the band and the Patriots
render prime you would look at it to say
what are we gonna be able to keep what
are we going to lose to primetime what
are we going to add us a doubleheader do
that New England at Seattle you got you
in minute the Chargers which by the way
if he ended up going to the church how
big is that game you know you England
and the Chargers in that new stadium and
Tom's on the other side you've got New
England against the Rams in that same
new stadium you got New England it's
Houston you let you England you got you
England in Kansas City you got two more
at New England I mean look at all these
games now if time is not better rich how
do you construct your schedule do you do
you still look at them as a network
programmer and more jobs and his team
from the NFL do you still look at this
team as a 10 and 6 11 and 5 12 and 14
then I'm going to put them at the header
window as the primary game four or five
times I'm going to give them five prime
time exposures because they've got meat
on the bone with the schedule with the
opponents we know they're going to play
next year then couldn't be in some big
spots
are you gonna risk that if they have to
go without top and it's a rebuild year
and and they've got to kind of like
reinvent themselves how much you give it
you give it a late season game - well -
- to NBC because you know are they at
that time they had sent in two team in
late November are they you know
something that was foreign to us are
they five and seven you know so there's
a lot that's going to be hinging on this
as we look forward to the fall and you
season Jim appreciate the time I know
you're traveling all around look forward
to the Gulf and March Madness that's to
come from your voice and I appreciate
the call let's chat soon
always great to visit with you thanks
for all that you do for us you're great
for the game and for us fans thank you
pal right back at you Jim
right back at you that's Jim Nantz right
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app